Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Jümisch. Ich bin hier des Ust-Stand-Garagstin für Sie. Ich werde mich um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern, aber vorher möchte ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufpassen. Bitte geben Sie mich Bescheid, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstanden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ich bin damit einverstanden.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Name, bitte?
Mein Name ist Müller, Klaus Müller.
Frau Müller.
Herr Müller, Klaus.
Herr Müller, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie, genau geboren?
Am 2. August 1964.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 m groß.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ungefähr 95 kg.
Okay.
Was für Sie sind Sie?
Herr Müller.
Ich habe jetzt ungefähr seit mehr als 5 Tagen Schmerzen im Bauch.
Wo genau sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Im Unterbauch.
Unterbauch.
Rechte oder saubt?
Die sind er unten.
Er ist linksseitig.
Linksseitig.
Was ist Ihr Name?
Was ist Ihr Name, bitte?
Ich bin ein bisschen in der Leiste.
Leiste.
Okay.
Wobei sind Sie aufgetreten?
Wie bitte?
Weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Was ist Ihr Name, bitte?
Ich bin ein bisschen in der Leiste.
Wobei sind Sie aufgetreten?
Sie sind aufgetreten oder saubt?
Wir sind ja so stechende Drücke in den Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala-Fond-Null-Bissin?
Wobei nur keine Schmerzen unter sehr starken Schmerzen sind.
Also wenn ich starke Schmerzen habe, sind die schon bei 7.
Es gibt auch Zeiten, wo ich weniger Schmerzen habe, aber manchmal sind die sehr stark.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Die gehen nicht weg, aber die werden weniger.
Sind die Schmerzen, die werden jetzt immer mehr?
Okay.
Was ist Ihr früher schon einmal in den Nehbäschwärden?
Ich habe das schon mal gehabt, vor ungefähr 2 Jahren.
Aber das ist dann von alleine wieder weggegangen.
Also das habe ich nichts gemacht.
Ich habe das abgewartet.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme Stuhlgang?
Ja, das ist jetzt unregelmäßig geworden.
Es ist manchmal fest, manchmal etwas flüssiger, weich.
Es ist immer unterschiedlich.
Das wundert mich ein bisschen.
Seit wann haben Sie die Beschwerden?
Ja, jetzt ungefähr seit einer Woche schon.
Eine Woche.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arschgewissen?
Nein, ich habe leider noch keine Zeit gehabt.
Ich musste die ganze Tage arbeiten, leider keine Zeit gehabt.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ich habe Übelkeit, ja.
Seit wann?
Auch seit 2 Tagen jetzt.
2 Tage.
Müssen Sie erbrechen?
Bis jetzt noch nicht.
Ich esse aber deutlich weniger.
Wie bitte?
Ich esse deutlich weniger.
Okay, weniger.
Also damit ich keine Übelkeit habe, esse ich weniger.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Eigentlich gut.
Aber wie gesagt, weil ich Übelkeit habe, esse ich etwas weniger.
Okay.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit ungeholt ab oder so genommen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber, Nachschweiß oder Stuhlfrost?
Ja, ich habe seit 2 Tagen messig.
Es ist immer so um die 38, 38, 5.
Ist schon so ein bisschen.
38,8?
Nein, 38, 38, 5 war das höchste.
Seit 2 Tagen?
Hab ich jetzt gemessen, ja.
Okay.
Nachschweiß oder Stuhlfrost?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Nein.
Gebt es bei Ihnen Atemnot, Bruce Schimmersen, Herzrausen oder Herzglocken?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme oder Schmerzen?
Nein, wie gesagt, habe ich nicht.
Ja, habe ich nicht. Haben Sie schon gefragt?
Haben Sie Blut in Ihren Urin bemerkt?
Nein, auch nicht.
Auch nicht? Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck schon seit mehreren Jahren.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Bis jetzt noch nicht. Gott sei Dank.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder geregelt Medikamente ein.
Ich nehme zwei Medikamente für den Blutdruck ein.
Welche Medikamente?
Ich nehme Kanle Satanein, 16 Milligramm und HCT, 12,5 Milligramm.
Wie bitte Ihre Wert, hbt?
Ich nehme Kanle Satanein, 16 Milligramm, einmal morgens und einmal HCT, 12,5 Milligramm, auch einmal morgens.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt ab und zu, habe ich Ibuprofen genommen wegen den Schmerzen.
Seit, ab und zu.
Zwei, drei Tage.
Ab und zu, seit der letzten Woche habe ich einmal eine genommen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel ich genommen habe, aber maximal einen am Tag.
Ja, wie viele Milligramm Ibuprofen?
400.
Hat es geholfen?
Ein bisschen.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergin oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft gegen Covid-19 oder Kinderkrankheit?
Ich glaube schon, also mein Haushaltsamt hat nichts gesagt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Ich hoffe nicht, nein.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal.
Also, wenn ich mit Freunden unterwegs bin.
Was trinken Sie?
Bier meistens, meistens Bier oder Wein.
Bier oder Wein, geregelt.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per se, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen so sich?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Rücken-Schmerzen?
Rücken-Schmerzen?
Jetzt akut nicht, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden jetzt aktuell?
Andere Beschwerden habe ich jetzt, wie gesagt, also bis auf die Unterbauchschmerzen,
im linken Unterbau auch für Märzende leistet,
habe ich eine Keil, nicht wirklich Schmerzen,
keine weiteren Beschwerden.
Nein.
Und habe ich Stuhlunregelmäßigkeiten?
Also, dass ich Stuhlunregelmäßigkeiten habe?
Manchmal Verstopfung, manchmal Durchfall.
Ja, das genau.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brut in Ihrem Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro, sachte Arbeiter.
Okay.
Wie ist Familienstand?
Ich bin bei Arbeiter.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben einen Sohn.
Ein Sohn?
Okay.
Haben Sie, haben Ihre Eltern vor Erkrankungen?
Also, meine Eltern hatten beide Bluthochdruck, beide sind verstorben
und meine Mutter hatte Diabetes.
Meine Vater hatte Schlaganfall.
Ja.
Meine Mutter hatte Magelkrebs.
Magelkrebs.
Verstorben.
Okay.
Ich habe ein Bruder, ja.
Ist er gesund?
Ich habe jetzt nicht viel Kontakt zu ihm,
aber ich glaube schon.
Ich habe auch einen Bruder.
Ich habe jetzt nicht viel Kontakt zu ihm,
aber ich glaube schon, der scheint bis uns zu sein.
Okay.
Ich habe für mich alle Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie eine Frage an mich, oder möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, also meine Mutter hat jetzt Magelkrebs gehabt.
Meinen Sie, das könnte bei mir auch so sein?
Was das mit dem Magelkrebs zu tun hat?
Ja.
Sie haben kein...
keine Brut in ihrer Stur.
Und keine Gewichtsverlust.
Deswegen vermute ich,
dass sie...
dass sie
darm
Entzündung haben.
Darm Entzündung?
Ja, darm Entzündung.
Darm Entzündung.
Darm Vertikulitis
kann sein.
Darm...
Darm Wald Entzündung haben.
Ich weiß,
beschwerden
kann nicht Magelkrebs.
Ich vermute.
Aber
das ist...
das ist
Verdarktdiagnose.
Das ist bestätigen.
Ich werde sie körpärlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich auch etwas Brut abnehmen.
Bei ihnen Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Eine Röntgenaufnahme machen lassen.
Nach einer Langemorgelung kann ich Ihnen Bescheid geben.
Okay, aber es ist kein Darm Entzündung.
Ja, vielleicht, aber...
Vielleicht.
Ja,
etwas zu sagen,
es ist zu früh um etwas zu sagen.
Nach einer Ergebnisse kann ich Ihnen Bescheid geben, was Sie haben.
Aber jetzt...
Wenn Sie glauben, ich habe Darm Entzündung,
dann...
Wie lange lebe ich dann noch? Meine Mutter ist echt früh gestorben.
Ja, aber ich vermute jetzt,
dass Sie Darm Wald Entzündung haben.
Ist das Darm Krebs?
Nein, nur Entzündung.
Ihre Beschwerden...
Es gibt viele verschiedene Ursachen, Ihre Beschwerden.
Zum Beispiel Entzündung, Viral, Bakterien...
Weil Sie haben Darm Krebs gesagt, deswegen bin ich es ein bisschen verwundert.
Ja, wie gesagt, es kann auch Darm Krebs sein.
Vielleicht, Darm Krebs sein.
Ja, ich vermute, dass Sie Darm Krebs haben.
Ach Gott sei Dank, ich dachte schon.
Ich dachte schon, dass ich Darm Krebs habe.
Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Muss ich heute hier bleiben oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Ich brauche, wir brauchen einige Untersuchungen.
Aber es ist zu früh um etwas zu sagen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Es ist zu früh um etwas zu sagen.
Untersuchungen dauert ca. 2-3 Stunden.
Ich kann nicht etwas gegen Schmerzen haben, ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Ja, ich gebe Schmerzmittel.
Aber Schmerzmittel kann unsere Untergäufe,
unsere Ergebnisse unter den Untersuchungen schädigen.
Es wäre besser für 10 Schmerzmittel.
Aber ich habe Schmerzen.
Deswegen bin ich ja hier.
Soll ich jetzt gleich Schmerzen machen?
Haben Sie noch Allergie gegen ihre Schmerzmittel?
Nein, ich habe es nicht.
Okay, ich habe Schmerzmittel.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe eine.
Gibt es etwas, das Schmerzen lindert oder verbessert?
Haben Sie etwas Bemäkt?
Wenn ich Stuhlgang gehabt habe, wird es besser.
Haben Sie dortbrennen, Behungen?
Haben Sie etwas Bemäkt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Noch Fragen?
Bitte schön.
Eine Frage ist, haben Sie eine Schwellung in der Leiste Bemäkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht Bemäkt.
Eine zweite Frage ist,
wann waren Sie letztes Mal im Hausarzt?
Hatten Sie eine Magenspiegelung gehabt?
Magenspiegelung?
Ja.
Da habe ich meine Hausarzt gesagt,
aber ich habe noch keine machen lassen.
Danke.
Eine gute Frage.
Noch eine Frage?
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Fettiges oder Walzstoffenreiches?
Normaler.
Aber was ist schon normal?
Könnte Sie das Schuhl genau beschreiben?
Das ist unregelmäßig und wechselnder Stuhlgang.
Manchmal Verstopfung, manchmal normaler, manchmal weicher Stuhlgang.
Aber sonst habe ich es nicht auffällig bemerkt.
Normaler.
Wie immer?
Physische Situation.
Ich bin momentan ziemlich gestresst auf der Arbeit.
Sport?
Ja, habe ich es regelmäßig.
Leider nicht, keine Zeit dafür.
Ich war auch nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Ja, ich war auch nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Ich habe mich nicht bemerkt.
Ich denke, die Frage ist schon fertig.
Können wir als Erster zu Beginn?
Gerne.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberraust.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patientin.
Darf ich ihn berichten?
Gerne.
Mein Patient Klaus Müller ist 6 Jahre alt.
Am Geboren 1. August 1904.
Am 1. August 1964.
1,85 m groß und 95 kg schwer.
Er stammt sich bei uns heute seit 5 Tagen.
Linke, Unterbauch, Schmerzen vor.
Er stammt sich bei uns seit 5 Tagen.
Er stammt sich seit 5 Tagen.
Linke, Unterbauch, Schmerzen vor.
Er hat Übelkeit ohne Emesis.
Ihre Appetit, seine Appetit ist gut.
Er hat seit zwei Tagen FIBA, 38,5.
Er hat Observation und Diary seit einer Woche.
Eine Woche ohne Blut.
Er hat was nochmal?
Er hat seit einer Woche Emendieren mundan.
Er hat eine Opposition, eine Oppositionsmusik, eine andere.
Er hat eine Blut.
Er hat ein weiterer Erkrankung.
Ein Moment, Herr Kollege, können Sie eine Stimmung vorstellen, nur am Tank?
Patient hat seit circa einer Woche zunehmende linksseitige in die leiste ausstrahlende Unterbauchschmerzen
mit wechselndem Stuhlverhalten Übelkeit ohne Erbrechen, subfibrillen Temperaturen
mit einer Schmerzkarre von 7 ungefähr.
Okay, danke schön, Herr Kollege. Bitte schön, Herr Tschein.
Als Vorarlkurankongol ist Arturialhypertoni seit mehr Jahren ernehmt Kandar-Zartan 80 mg morgens
80, 16, 16, 16, 16, 16, 16.
16, 16, 16, 16.
Okay, HST, 12,5 mg morgens und Ibukrofen 400 mg ab und zu, unklar, dosis ein.
400 mg bei Bedarf.
Ja, absolut.
Aber nicht unklar, dosis.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich schuldigung.
Er hat keine Operation.
Er ist nicht raha.
Trink, geregenheitlich, Bia oder Wein.
Er ist in der Büro, ist verheiratet, hat einen Sohn.
Seine Vater hat Arturialhypertoni, ist an Apoplexy verstorben.
Seine Mutter hat Arturialhypertoni und Diabetes Melutus,
ist an Magen Karsten und Verstorben.
Seine Bruder, seine Bruder, ja, er hat einen Bruder, aber nicht kontaktiert.
Ja, kein Kontakt, sei gesund.
Sein Bruder sei gesund.
Ja, meine Vardagdiagnose ist Reis-Darm-Syndrom.
Astrophraziardiagnosen kommen, Dwardklutis und Darmkrebs im Betrag.
Um meine Vardagdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten
körperlich untersuchen und Vitalparameter messen.
Ich möchte Blutbild, Ersündungsparameter, Nieranwalte,
Lebewalte, Studiagnostik, verordnen.
Eine Röntgenaufnahme, abdomen-Röntgenaufnahme machen lassen,
bei der Patienten Ultrasonografie,
Sonneabdoman, Durführen, Koloskopie,
Ferranasen.
Okay, das ist okay.
Sie haben die Vardagdiagnose-Reis-Darm-Syndrom gesagt.
Richtig?
Ja.
Wie können Sie das bestätigen?
Wie kann man eine Reis-Darm-Syndrom in der Notaufnahme bestätigen?
Ich treffe bei der Arbeit und sie hat versto-
Nein, meine Frage ist, wie können Sie das bestätigen?
Wie können Sie eine Reis-Darm-Syndrom in der Notaufnahme bestätigen?
Können Sie das überhaupt?
Okay, okay.
Reis-Darm-Syndrom ist psychosomatische Erkrankung aus Zulchlissen-Krankheit.
Aus Schlußdiagnose?
Aus Schlußdiagnose.
Koloskopie ist wichtig für Diagnose.
Es gibt keine Pathologie in Kolon, Magen und so.
Genau.
Deswegen ist es sinnvoller, wenn Sie die zweite Diagnose nehmen,
Ihre Verdachtdiagnose, die Vertikulitis.
Weil dann können Sie Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose
immer somatisch sein.
Sie sind in einer somatischen Klinik,
also innere Medizin oder Syrogy.
Und wenn Sie den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, nichts finden,
dann können Sie als Auslußdiagnose eventuell Reis-Darm-Syndrom sagen.
Aber bitte nicht als erste Diagnose Reis-Darm-Syndrom sagen.
Das ist eine psychosomatische psychogene Erkrankung,
die zwar auch Beschwerden macht,
aber das können Sie nicht in der Ambulanz untersuchen.
Es geht nicht.
Dafür brauchen Sie, müssen Sie alle anderen Erkrankungen ausschließen,
damit Sie das sagen können.
Von daher würde ich sagen, es ist eine Differenzialdiagnose,
Reis-Darm-Syndrom, aber ich würde die zweite Verdachtdiagnose,
die Sie gesagt haben, mit die Vertikulitis,
das ist die wahrscheinlichste Diagnose.
Warum?
Er hat linkszeitig Unterbauchschmerz, Subpfebril,
das Ganze wird immer mehr.
Sie haben nicht gefragt,
wenn Sie draufdrücken, ob es schmerzt,
ob die Schmerzintensität zunehmend, haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Wenn Sie den untersuchen,
sollten Sie mal draufdrücken, ob die Nickenunterbauch,
ob es mehr wird.
Wenn das, dann haben Sie eigentlich schon fast die Diagnose,
die Vertikulitis bestätigt
und können Reis-Darm-Syndrom ausschließen wiederum.
Deswegen sollte man den Patienten
erst mit einer somatischen Erkrankung untersuchen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Sie haben die Verdachtdiagnose, die Vertikulitis,
Sie haben alles richtig gesagt,
Sie nehmen Entzündungsparameter ab, Sie untersuchen,
den Patienten machen eine Ultraschall des Bauchaums,
röntgen es auch gut,
sehr gut, um ein vielleicht doch eventuell Ilius
auszuschließen oder freie Luft auszuschließen,
ist nicht schlecht, vollkommen richtig.
Und jetzt haben Sie Blutabgenommen
und du hast die Therapie von der Diagnose.
Therapie,
Anagesäkverordnung,
Antibiotikum.
Okay, erregt das Ibuprofen ein?
Ja, Ibuprofen oder Metamizol.
Okay.
Und Antibiotika?
Ja, Antibiotika,
Antibiotika, Metamidosol
oder Zweite, Dreite,
Sephalosoporin,
vielleicht,
Phylusikalsufur,
Nährungskaren.
Muss man nicht machen.
Ja, muss man.
Okay, das war es oder machen Sie noch etwas,
wenn Sie die Patientin stationär aufnehmen?
Stationär aufnehmen, ja.
Kann man machen, ne?
Muss man nicht machen, aber kann man machen.
Vielen Dank,
Herr Kollege, ich bin der Professor,
der uns die Simulation aufzeichnet.
Okay.
Und welche Simulation?